une tante un abri pour un grand objectif
sauver des vies indigènes peut-on lire
sur la pancarte de cette pharmacie de
compagnie les habitants de manaus
attentifs aux conseils des infirmiers et
soignante face à une deuxième vague
préoccupante tour med est bon a essayé
se tait qui contient du citron de l'ail
et du manga ratahya le manga taïa est
appelée gingembre sur la langue des
blancs il sert à se gargariser et en
prendre un peu pour donner l'immunité
aux gens l'immunité et plus largement
l'immunité collective une doctrine qui
fait débat au brésil et dans le monde
après la publication de cet article par
la revue science
on y apprend que 76 % de la population
de manaus avait contracté le virus en
octobre 2020 avec l'espoir justement de
laisser le virus se propage et au
maximum au sein de la population et qui
au-delà d'un certain seuil ne pourra
plus atteindre qu'un être humain
stratégie qui ne semble pas payé face
notamment variant venu d'amazonie manaus
a déjà vécu plus de 3000 en termes en
janvier le mois le plus meurtrier depuis
le début de la pandémie officiellement
le virus est responsable de presque la
moitié des décès je suis
particulièrement inquiète pour les
prochaines semaines dans toute notre
région en particulier en amérique du
nord et du sud
de nombreux hôpitaux fonctionnent à
pleine capacité ou presque
les rapports de manaus au brésil
illustre ce qui se passe lorsqu'un
système de santé n'a pas la capacité
suffisante pour faire face à la rapidité
des nouvelles infections en dépit de
revenus des hôpitaux surchargés avec une
pénurie de lits et d'oxygène alors que
le brésil a débuté sa vaccination
seulement le 17 janvier un pays qui
compte plus de 210 millions d'habitants
son président jr bolson arômes réticents
à l'adoption de mesures restrictives est
pointé du doigt une immunité collective
choisit également par la suède la
grande-bretagne ou encore par le
gouvernement de donald trump
tous ont finalement décidé de faire
machine arrière
les etats unis pays le plus touché au
monde la grande bretagne nation
européenne la plus meurtrie fin décembre
le roi de suède à lui reconnu son échec
à la télévision même si les vaccins
commençaient à protéger les plus
vulnérables nous n'atteindrons aucun
niveau d'immunité de la population ou d'
immunité collective en 2021
et même si cela se produit dans quelques
poches de quelques pays
cela ne protégera pas les gens dans le
monde immunité collective vaccin pour l'
oms le respect des gestes barrières
restent pour l'heure le seul moyen
efficace de se protéger contre le virus